[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Let's start with
an existing GCP project,
then open the IAM page
on the GCP console
from the top left
navigation menu.
Up at the top, click Add.
Enter the email address
for a new person,
someone not already in
the access list shown.
Then you can choose what
role to add them to.
I'm picking Storage Admin.
That will give this
account control
over Cloud storage resources.
Now, switch to the
account you just added.
At first, I have no permissions
to see storage resources.
Permissions are propagating.
It just takes a few seconds.
After a reload, I can see
the photo I stored earlier,
because I'm Storage Admin.
I can modify or delete the file.
If I remove that member
from the IAM list,
the account loses permissions.
Reloading the
storage browser page,
I get a permissions error,
because the account no longer
is allowed to view
storage resources.
[MUSIC PLAYING]